[Musique]
les etats unis ont confirmé aujourd'hui
la réouverture de la frontière avec le
mexique avec le canada avec plusieurs
autres pays dans le monde à partir du
mois de novembre la relation commerciale
canada etats unis c'est 900 milliards de
dollars par année vous savez durant la
pandémie les frontières sont quand même
rester ouvertes pour le commerce mais
quand même sur le plan économique qu'est
ce que ça signifie que cette réouverture
de la frontière avec le gym ou jimmy
jean économiste en chef de desjardins
bonsoir bonsoir quel est l'impact
économique que ça va avoir la
réouverture l'annnonce de la réouverture
des frontières par les américains pas ce
qui est intéressant c'est que en temps
normal il ya plus de canadiens qui se
déplace aux états unis que yo
d'américains qui se déplace au canada
les canadiens dépensent plus aux états
unis les américains dépensent au canada
qui ont un solde commercial des voyages
qui est difficile tant en temps normal
or pendant la pandémie avec la fermeture
des frontières on a vu une forte
diminution de ce déficit de la et donc
c'était favorable pour l'économie
canadienne sur un sens purement
comptable de comptabilité de la
croissance donc on a eu moins de déficit
et les canadiens ont dépensé cet argent
là au niveau local donc ce qui va
arriver avec la réouverture de ces
frontières là évidemment on va revoir ce
difficile à augmenter alors qu'une plus
grande partie du budget va être allouée
à des dépenses qu'on veut comme dans le
passé aux etats unis les gens vont se
déplacer en voiture entre autres visiter
la côte est ce donc c'est un peu un
retour à la normale ça a un impact
négatif point de vue pib mais ça va être
positif sur le moral ils ont dès lors ce
matin oui exactement donc le solde
commercial qui était positive depuis le
début de la pandémie ou au cours de la
pandémie va où pourrait en tout cas
revenir négatif c'est ça ça va avoir un
effet négatif de ce côté là ok
d'un autre côté est ce que la hausse des
prix pourrait se calmer contenu qui
aurait peut-être un petit peu moins de
pression quant à la demande à
l'intérieur là c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec ça parce qu'on le
décrit comme un côté négatif mais
prenons le contexte actuel qu'est ce
qu'on a observé avec cette réallocation
des budgets là on observait des fortes
dépenses dans des biens durables par
exemple les véhicules récréatifs c'est
une des façons dont les gens ont
substitué
ses voyages la confusion normalement à
l'étranger donc on a substitué soit pour
des véhicules récréatifs par exemple ou
encore des dépenses dans l'immobilier ou
encore le dépenser plus dans des
destinations régionales touristique
locale donc et ça crée beaucoup de
pression pression sur les prix pression
sur la main d'oeuvre la demande donc
c'est une demande pour laquelle
l'économie canadienne n'est pas
configuré
pour répondre totalement cette demande
c'est ce qu'on voit c'est pour ça que
les prix augmentent et pour ce qui est
de l'inflation donc en quelque part là
le retour à la normale ou une partie du
profil de consommation des ménages va
vers l'étranger savor soulagent un petit
peu de suppressions là qu'on subit
actuellement d'ouverture des frontières
vers les états unis pourrait on pourrait
aller jusqu à alléger le contexte
inflationniste où on a un taux
d'inflation record là en près de deux
décennies ça va ça va être un petit peu
évidemment il va falloir qu'ils et
autres éléments on sait que la banque du
canada va augmenter ses tours du monde
s'attend à ce que le monde sait tout
l'année prochaine donc ça aussi ça va
être un autre facteur mais ce retour à
la normale
où les dépenses sont plus
conformes à ce qu'on voit habituellement
ça va être ça va être bénéfique
évidemment il ya un autre envers la
médaille c'est que les américains eux
aussi peuvent venir au canada depuis
depuis le mois d'août donc il faut
toujours voir ça honnête mais comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure où net c'est que on
dépense plus aux etats unis qu eux
dépensent ici et salons faire en sorte
que
cet argent là qui été réallouée à
l'économie locale va sortir à l'étranger
on va le voir dans un graphique dans un
tableau que vous avez préparé pour nous
les dépenses de voyages des canadiens
aux états unis avant la crise on était
rendu presque à 26 milliards de dollars
en dépenses de voyages côtes américaines
oui tout à fait donc et on voit comment
on l'a plongé à 8 milliards seulement en
2020 et jusqu'à présent 2021
niveau de dépenses a été très faible ça
c'est encore une fois cet écart là c'est
de l'argent qui a été
réinvesti réallouer dans des dépenses au
canada qui aussi est épargné jusqu'à un
certain degré mais tout se fait en sorte
que c'est redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux consommateurs or quand il n'y a pas
la capacité au niveau de l'économie pour
répondre à toute la demande dans tous
les secteurs
ce que ça fait c'est que ça crée de
l'inflation donc c'est pas une situation
qui way qui nécessite vraiment scène
donc on peut accueillir ce positivement
dans le sens où ça va peut-être jeté un
peu d'eau froide ce qu'on a besoin du
plus haut niveau de l'inflation si le
dollar canadien 8 à 81 cents américains
est ce que ça va inciter les canadiens
redire ça vaut la peine d'aller aux
etats-unis c'est un peu plus intéressant
avec un dollar plus élevé tout à fait ça
peut également jouer fausse appris quand
même que dans les cinq dernières années
la moyenne du dollar canadien ça et et
76 cents donc on à fluctuer dans une
fourchette allant des 70 c'est no 83
cents chronique encore à l'intérieur de
cette fourchette le globalement mais
c'est certain que par rapport à où on
était avant la pandémie ça devient moins
coûteux avec l'effet du dollar canadien
qui s'est renchérie par contre les prix
de l'essence sont très chers à l'heure
actuelle les prix des voyages qu'on
regarde l'inflation dans les hôtels aux
etats unis c'est 20 % en variation
annuelle donc là aussi il faut
s'attendre à ce que certaines factures
coûte plus cher parce que là-bas aussi
il ya des pénuries de main d'oeuvre là
bas aussi les choses coûtent pas plus
cher il ya tous les enjeux dans les
chaînes d'approvisionnement également
jimmy jean merci ça me fait plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne i hier 10